oui
seiler électrique
au soir au célèbre shopping valley
et offre donc à l'italie
mardi à
la luna
à la nourrir ras
al-amoud toros à la montre à vous
l'écrire et jeanine chez m inch'allah
mesdames
mesdemoiselles et messieurs nous leur
assistance quel plaisir de me retrouver
dans cette enceinte
chargé d'histoire chargé de souvenirs
parce que les plus grands que votre
exclusion faite césaire il croire de
sud un des grands des organisateurs que
je félicite pour ce qu'ils ont fait ils
stressent et aujourd'hui il veut se
peint pour récompenser je vais zine
partager avec vous quelques si
je le verrai également
vu mon âge parce qu'apparemment salon on
appartient parce que j'ai déjà consommé
3 buts
en expérience oui mais encore à vous
servir mon expérience en quinze jours je
vais essayer de me parler quelque peu de
ce qu'on peut appeler réussir sa vie
professionnelle et personnelle et même
mourir ma vie professionnelle et
personnelle cela exige ou de résistance
un certain nombre d'ingrédients on peut
appeler et haneda ce qu'on appelle
comme nous le rappellent quotidiennement
la réalité certains d'entre nous sont
plus ou moins prépare à prendre des
biens sur leur environnement que ce soit
dans le travail ou dans le cadre
familial
d'autres un peu moins il existe
assurément une base à mon sens génétique
et cela devient évident quand on observe
des composants de la réussite tel ce
qu'on appelle le quotient de délai
il est clair probablement certainement
sûrement que je ne pense que je voudrais
ce soit partager avec vous que la
capacité intellectuelle constitue un
critère important de réussite mais mais
parce qu'il ya toujours des nez dans
cette vie c'est ça qui est bon
l'imagination pour l'épanouissement
scène le quotient intellectuel est
important mais l'intelligence
émotionnelle et collectives ainsi que
l'expérience et les circonstances seront
là nous permettront de contrer lieu de
façon moment
qu'aux intellectuelle revers éléments
importants à nos sens deuxième élément
important ce qu'on peut appeler le
destin auquel nous croyons tous parce
que vous savez il nous arrive on connaît
tous ces histoires où la poisse colle
aux basques de certains alors qu'ils
avaient tout en main pour réussir où il
échoue lamentablement dans leur vie de
famille quand bien même
ils sont brillants sur le plan
intellectuel et professionnel
les compétences techniques à nos sens et
l'expérience professionnelle
favoriser la réussite d'une carrière
mais pas forcément du succès tels seul
le membre des libres entre la vie
professionnelle et familiale et
personnelle et souvent la cause de
problèmes nous avons tous des
aspirations
nous avons tous des ambitions nous avons
tous les objectifs nous avons tous
également des projets mais cela va être
tributaire de ce qu'on appelle éléments
divergents et des repères culturels mais
aussi les valeurs d'une telle chaque à
partir de là la troisième question qu'on
se pose dans cette intervention c'est
celle de savoir est ce que la réussite
professionnelle et personnelle se
commande
est là mesdames mesdemoiselles et
messieurs le thème planification rentrer
en jeu et oui on va après mon prof de
management paris la fameuse des bottes
pdc a plein tout chez act j'essayais de
la pratique et dans ma vie de tous les
jours
à mon sens tout succès quelques il
sourit tout succès est incontestablement
le résultat d'une volonté in et son
attelle au nom
qui est neige dans l'inconscient de la
rumeur mais cela mesdames mesdemoiselles
et messieurs passe inévitablement par un
effort constant
dessin quotient intellectuel
engagement mais également efforts on
n'obtient rien sans rien l'homme à mon
sens un dégroupage bien sûr record d'un
énorme pouvoir et d'un potentiel pour
progresser et là il n'y a pas de secret
le lien était ami et petit à petit nous
allons essayer de fait au fur et à
mesure des bilans de compétences
probablement voir un point fort dans le
temps d'amener sa des problèmes
aujourd'hui compères bien on dit les
points à améliorer
les tests la formation les définition
objective est nécessaire si l'on
h2o de
nombreux d'entre nous les dames et
demoiselles et les cieux rechignent à le
faire à faire ces bilans de compétences
car ils craignent qu'en cas d'échec par
rapport aux objectifs en termes de
carrière cela puisse être interprété
comme une défaite personnelle et une
remise en cause de ce qu'on appelle la
provence en individuel a gagné parce que
cours de l'une des valeurs prévalant
actuellement dans notre cité les chefs
et cyril d'une dévalorisation de
l'individu qu'est ce que j'avais peur au
mois de juin
j'attire
c'était sain
cette stratégie
machine
et dont nous allons petit à petit
cultiver ce procès ce qui va permettre
vous voulez 2 analyser profondément ce
qu'on appelle les analyses des chais
monnet divulgué à mon sens
ces éléments découle du manque de prise
de conscience et d'efforts pour
progresser elle laisse également du
refus de faire appel à autrui dans la
construction de sa réussite
une langue dérivée
à mon sens également le succès n'est pas
une question de chance
erreur fondamentale
car je placerais la chance de ce qu'on
appelle les opportunités
mesdames mesdemoiselles et messieurs
je n'aurais jamais la foi inébranlable
de mon père
ni la négation ni le courage ni la
patience de ma mère
je ne pourrai jamais égalé la science
acquise de ma grande soeur
ni avoir le charisme de mon petit frère
encore moins la beauté de mac os 10
je suis moi
est ce que je suis moi même
depuis plusieurs décennies je fais le
maximum pour me faire plaisir au service
de la famille petites et grandes de mes
proches et de mes seuls au service de
mon prochain avec mes défauts certes
mais également avec les qualités non
négligeable j'ai connu de victoire si la
mégère enregistrez les dépêches au
niveau professionnel et personnel j'ai
savouré une première autour d'un verre
de thé censure et j'ai retenu la leçon
pour les seconds afin de reculer pour
mieux sauter et oui mesdames
mesdemoiselles déçu j'avais prévu une
présentation mais je vais partir
rapidement vers quatre dates
salvati qui ont jalonné si vous le
souhaitez map petit
mais symbole gm
parce que si on les dépeint médecins et
ingénieurs
vous n'êtes rien
et j'ai mené pour devenir ingénieur
bêtement mais parce qu'un jour en créant
la société
j'étais obligé parce que dans leur
calvaire il fallait que je les gêner
réponse et
ça m'a coûté très cher reçu parce que
dix années après et ben n'ai pas à
décider que je sois main posée sur
bordeaux a plus qu un g1 mommessin non
je suis un citoyen du monde pour
partager des eaux
1980 c'était l'année du bac
qu'est ce que je vais faire
je suis pas dit également en france et
j'ai commencé à faire ça c'est vous une
belle manche qui m'a appris beaucoup de
choses petit à petit et d'arrivée une
importante que je n'ai pas mis ici c'est
celle où j'ai allemand je suis revenu au
maroc pour partager une expérience dans
un institut du tourisme belle expérience
humaine où je suis passé moi j'ai eu la
chance de faire la mission mais c'est
pas un échange vous à ceux d'accor ces
lycées comme un nombre il y à de belles
choses dans les lycées marocains et j'en
suis fier il ya quelques serveurs
actuellement de plastique mais comme si
ce dernier n'est pas avec nous ce soir
on peut se permettre aussi
1980 6 inchangé carrière
on m'a dit qu'est ce que tu vas faire et
j'ai dit à mes parents je vais
travailler dans un os n'est en bois
devant ma vie me servait
alors de loin mais
j'ai partagé et j'ai pris la décision ce
fut une réussite est-ce que ce fut l
échelle je les analyse et petit à petit
j'ai appris beaucoup de choses
1989 mon premier chat avec mon employeur
où j'ai essayé de ne pas être médium
mais on est connaisseur de paille
guillaume gillet mon supérieur démarche
war j'ai déjà
des raids sans mona jésus
expérience parce qu'il voulait le
licencier sur 1 incroyable et un penseur
doivent rien n'est ce
pas
mais les chats les rats à l'événement
j'ai fait la vie la vie des grains qui
m'a appris que dans ce processus il faut
décider vous allez décider
1992 j'ai travaillé pour des employeurs
et mon belmadi rien grandi à l'ombre des
grands arbres
il a raison je ne devrais pas structure
et je veux ma journée mais pour essayer
d'en faire quelque chose
1997 une belle teinte j'ai rencontré
série partage ma vie
douce moitié
celle qui me supportent et qui m'a
demandé tout à l'heure à guéret novembre
elle croit je vais aller voir ma
maîtresse d'école
non du tout dunod je suis fidèle jusqu'à
preuve du contraire
be nice
18 2002 deux bouts d'choux les chinois
j'essaie d'en faire deux semaines et
demie des éléments comme où je serai un
jour qu'ils fassent également connaître
h tu passe bien sûr
mesdames mesdemoiselles et messieurs
vous savez avec ses enfants la vie a
pris un nouveau sens elle sujet réussi
je ne sais pas encore parce qu'ils n'ont
de 10 ans et 14 ans parce que je me suis
mariée sur le départ mais passerait pas
mesdames et messieurs si vous pensez que
j'ai réussi ma prestation alors je veux
je souhaite et j'exige une sellerie
mauvais j si vous pensez le contraire
fait semblant d'applaudir
pour la simple et bonne raison mesdames
et messieurs c'est que cela encouragera
sans doute pour vergne et la prochaine
fois et améliorer l'état dans nos 22 et
de communicateur
soyez de la race des winners les hommes
sont liés à 69/100 vous
apprendre pour cent un subtil dosage
entre la volonté et la foi et les
prendre au sens qu'il reste
croyez en votre destin et on va leur
destinée je vis neyret comme a commencé
soit menée a gobé par deux citations une
en français et une aux marins
le futur n'est pas un endroit où nous
avons mais un lieu de nous créer les
chemins ne sont pas à construire mais ne
sont pas trouvées pardon mais à
construire à jaca à cirer d'avis chiffre
ressort à l'international et comme mon
nom à la manche en prenant l'une et
l'autre ont dit qu'ils avaient pris leur
douche et des trios en droit ni en sa
qualité de joueur on est tout de même
être la bonne salut a tous demandé où
j'allais des idées à travers tout autre
niveau alors je serai ravie à l'effet
ramadan
folco galli
on est là
dans nos salles
merci et dans douze mois